Now that we have a good understanding
of modern application design,
I'm pretty sure our next
step is to deploy our code.
Now I'm thinking about
application dependencies.
I'm thinking about how
to build packets and
distribute all of these applications,
and this seems like a lot of work.
Kelsey, is there any way around this?
>> One option would be figure
out all your dependencies and
build a native package for every
Linux distro you plan to support or
you can skip all of that and
build a container image.
>> What's a container image?
>> A container image is a packaging
format that includes not
only your application, but
all your dependencies or
runtime information required to run it.
Think about your mobile phone.
You download a self-contained
application and run it.
Containers do the same thing but
for your servers.
>> So this is something that's
available on servers today?
>> Close.
The container technology is built
into most major operating systems,
including Linux and Windows, but it's
not exactly easy to use out of the box.
You'll need something like Docker
which provides a nice API on top of
container technology and
makes it easy to create, distribute,
and run container images
on your own servers.
Okay, I get it.
You know,
given the available options, and
my sanity, it seems like container
images are the way to go.